All right,
so you have the chaos that surrounds you and it's some,
some sense,
infinite in scope,
and then you have the order that you produce,
which is your mastery of it.
Well,
let's take order apart for a minute.
We want to think about the structure of order and bill.
And I'm not saying that chaos is bad in order is good.
I'm not saying that at all.
That's not the right way to look at it.
It's the balance.
It's the balance between the mets of crucial importance.
They,
they exist as superordinate categories.
Whether you liked them or not is really not that relevant there.
There,
there,
there the fundamental constituent elements of reality.
Um,
you might say,
well,
what's your evidence for that?
And I can tell you one piece of evidence,
which I won't go into for for very much time.
You have two hemispheres in each,
in your brain.
The brain is composed of two hemispheres,
which implies something about the nature of the world.
Given that your brain is hypothetically adapted to the structure of the world.
It's not just your brain cause animal brains have the same fundamental
structure,
this bifurcated structure and the bifurcation indicates that there's two
fundamental realities because otherwise why would you need a bifurcated
structure or maybe you need to try you in brain or one that's divided into four
but that isn't what you have.
You have one that's divided into two and if your working definition of reality
is scientific,
biological,
let's say,
then your definition of reality is reality is that which shapes life.
You can't actually do better than that from a Darwinian perspective and if the
reality that shape life produced a bifurcated representational structure,
then that implies that the proper way to represent reality and perhaps that
reality itself is in fact bifurcated and I believe it's bifurcated in the manner
I just described and the neurological evidence for that is actually quite
overwhelming.
It's come from multiple sources,
some of them Russian,
some of them American.
That's where most of the work has been done.
Your left hemisphere is specialized for operation in those situations that you
know and understand and your right hemisphere is specialized for operation in
those situations that you neither know nor understand.
And the proper way to Orient Yourself in life is to get the balance between
those two sets of operations.
Correct.
And the way that manifests itself in your subjective experiences as meaningful
engagement.
And so that's not a bad first pass.
What would you say?
Justification for the view that these two domains are the most real domains.
Okay,
so order.
What is order?
Well,
if you just sit there and do nothing,
that will be chaos.
Why?
Well,
because you'll,
you'll suffer and die.
That's what will happen.
So without action on your part,
deterioration and death is a certainty.
Okay?
So you need to act well then we built on an action platform.
I mean we're the consequence of
3 billion years of evolution for action,
action,
movement forward in the face of necessity is the prime dictum of life.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
Were embodied action.
What do you have to do when you act?
Well,
at minimum you have to do whatever keeps you able to act.
These are truisms,
right?
I mean,
you have to have something to eat.
You have to have some fresh water.
You need some shelter,
right?
You need some companionship.
You need a sexual partner,
you need children,
you need play.
You need to be touched.
There's there's,
and I mean,
I actually mean need by the way.
People deprived to play go insane.
People who aren't touched,
die.
These things are necessary.
Well,
assuming that survival itself is necessary,
but we'll start with that.
We'll start with the assumption that just sitting there and suffering and dying
is not the right solution.
Okay?
So you have to act in the world.
You have to act in the world that in a manner that stops you from deteriorating
and dying at minimum.
And that means that you have to address the problems that are intrinsic to that
destiny.
Now you have all sorts of systems that evolved,
have evolved to help you do that.
Motivational systems,
we have to eat.
So you get hungry.
You have to find water and consume it so you get thirsty.
You get lonely,
you get curious.
There's,
there's,
there's specialized biological systems that are very,
very old.
You get aggressive,
you get afraid,
you,
you suffer pain,
all those,
there's specialized systems for all of those unit directional systems of
orientation in the world.
And they help you figure out what to do.
So when you're hungry,
it's time to eat.
And when you're thirsty it's,
it's time to drink.
And when your lonesome,
it's time to seek out some companionship.
And you have specialized systems that help you do that.
But they're not enough because,
well,
they're not very bright.
That's one way of looking at it.
They're kind of uni dimensional and you also have the problem of organizing all
of them.
It's like,
well,
you have to eat now and you have to drink now and you need a companion.
It's probably time to play and you have to do something about shelter.
And there isn't just you right now.
There's you now and tomorrow and next week and a year from now and five years
from now.
So you have to plan across all those stretches of time and there isn't just you
now in the future,
you,
there's you plus your family and your community and so all of that has to be
taken into account while you're plotting your movement forward is very,
very complicated.
You have all these problems to solve simile,
tiniest [inaudible] and your motivational systems,
anger,
hunger and so forth can help you solve one of those problems now,
but not all of them permanently.
That requires higher cognitive function and that's part of what drove the
evolution of our complex cognitive systems.
That's how do you propagate the game across time in a complex environment.
The left hemisphere operates when,
where,
when what you're doing works and so a lot of what you do during your life is to
keep your right hemisphere off.
People don't like it going on accidentally.
It's the home of negative emotion.
It's the home of pain and anxiety.
It's the thing that turns on and freezes you in your tracks when something that
you deeply did not expect happens and it prepares you to deal with the onslaught
of what you didn't expect.
Now it's not all bad news because to use the right hemisphere in a judicious
manner is also something that adds intrigue and interest in artistic expression
and all sorts of positive things to your life.
So because potential is not only negative,
it's also positive,
it can be,
it can be dealt with in ways that are deeply enriching and meaningful
order.
Okay,
so you have to do something.
Otherwise the consequences are dire.
To do something you have to value something.
It's it's,
it's a definitional issue because to do something is to act out the proposition
that the thing you're doing,
the thing you're aiming at,
let's say it's preferable to the thing you have and preferable means you'll do
it.
So those things are tied together so tightly.
You can't disentangle them.
If you say,
I'm aiming at x,
but I don't value it,
then there's something wrong with the way that you're conceptualizing the
statement.
Because to aim at something and to work to bring it into existence is the same
as valuing it.
And if you say,
well,
I don't value it,
then something's out of kilter.
Either you're acting out a false hood or you don't know what you're talking
about.
It's one of those two things and you meet people like that are deeply confused
there.
Their action patterns and their verbal self representation don't Mesh,
but that doesn't mean that they're critics of value.
It just means that they're deeply confused.
So you have to act or you suffer.
In order to act,
you have to have a value structure because to act you have to value one thing
more than another,
which means that you have to inhabit a structure of value.
You have to,
okay,
so you need a structure value because it's the antidote to catastrophe.
Now,
if you act out a structure of values socially,
which you will cause you're social,
you're not going to pursue your aims in isolation because you're not,
you're not a solitary animal.
You're a social animal,
you're a tribal animal.
Deeply tribal.
We live in groups,
we live in families,
we live in communities.
We live in large societies were social at every level of analysis and we've been
social for as long as we've been primates.
So maybe that's,
that's at least 6 million years and it might be more like 60 million years.
It's really a long time.
So it's not an arbitrary social construction.
It's far,
far deeper than that.
Now what happens when you act out a structure of value in a social environment,
you produce a hierarchy inevitably.
Well,
let's think it through.
Why?
Well,
let's say that you say that one thing is more worth doing then another,
whatever happens to be,
and then you tell a bunch of people about what you're doing and they decide that
they're going to come along and help you do this thing that's valuable because
they also think it's valuable and maybe you get 20 people together to do this
thing,
whatever it happens to me.
And the first thing you discover is that some of the people are way better at
doing whatever it is that they're doing than other people.
So,
and that,
and who knows why that is?
Because it depends on what you chose to do,
you know?
If you chose a,
then it would be a different group of people who were good at it.
Then if you chose B,
because people differ in their abilities.
But one thing you will not escape from if you make an organization to do
something valuable is the brute fact that it will be a minority of the people
who are good at doing it.
And there's actually a law,
it's called price's law,
and it's a real law,
even governs the size of cities and the massive stars in the heights of plants
in the jungle.
It just doesn't govern human interactions.
And price's law says that the square root of the number of people engaged in an
enterprise,
we'll do half the work.
So if you have 10 people doing something,
three of them,
we'll do half the work.
But if you have a hundred people doing something,
then 10 of them will do half the work.
And if you have 10,000 people doing something than a hundred of them,
we'll do half the work.
And the,
you know how wealth distributes itself such that a minority of people have most
of the money,
1285 richest people in the world have as much money as the bottom,
two and a half billion.
It's something like that.
And everybody goes,
oh my God,
the 1% it's like,
well,
first of all,
you're all the 1% so get over yourself because you're,
you know,
western European,
roughly speaking and by world current world standards,
and certainly by historical standards,
you're all well ensconced in the 1% so if that's a problem,
well it's a problem for all of you.
And some of you might be,
you know,
richer than that,
but that doesn't mean all of you aren't in the same boat.
Fundamentally,
the fact that wealth aggregates in the hands of a small number of people is part
of the general expression of price's.
There's nothing special about the distribution of money.
You see the same thing in every creative domain.
I mean,
how many of you have have recorded a
gold record?
How many looks like zero up?
There's one,
one person,
okay,
there's 850 people in here.
So there's one in a thousand so that's one 10th of 1% something like that.
How many of you have written a piano concerto?
How about painted a painting that's hanging in a national museum?
Oh look,
it's none of you again.
Right?
Well,
and how many of you have been a member of a professional sports team?
Okay,
look up one one.
So that's one in a thousand.
Well you get the point here.
Well if there was a couple,
there was.
Okay,
so it looks like it's easier to be a member of a professional sports team
or my or my audiences is biased.
The samples biased but,
but it is the case.
If you look at high levels of creative achievement of the sort of just described
they can,
they characterize it staggering minority of people.
And so the rule is is that you produce a value system which you better produce
because otherwise you suffer and die.
And it isn't the only,
the only that it's like,
look,
here's something else you all know.
As far as I can tell,
we start with the idea that there's an intrinsic,
chaotic element to life and that includes the inevitability of suffering and
malevolence betrayal at the hands of yourself and other people.
So that's the baseline.
And that's intolerable in many ways because life is in many ways intolerable.
And the question is,
well,
what do you do in the face of something that's intolerable?
And answer is,
will you try to find something that justifies it right?
You want to have something that gets you the hell out of bed in the morning and
not just any old morning,
but a morning when your father has Alzheimer's disease and your daughter has an
incurable illness because you need something to get out of bed for in those
mornings too.
And that better be the purpose that you found in life.
And if the purpose is going to be such that it gets you out of bed in those
mornings,
it better be a pretty damn noble purpose because otherwise,
why would you bother?
And so not only do you need a value structure,
you need one that's of sufficient tension,
let's say,
or sufficient value or sufficient nobility so that it's worth suffering for
because you're going to suffer and you better have something that makes the
suffering justifiable.